avignon suite et fin le festival se
termine le journal aussi alors dernier
spectacle dans la cour d'honneur la
compagnie de danse près le blocage pour
un hommage au ballet russe qui ont été
les pères fondateurs de la danse
contemporaine
michel trudeau ici michel levasseur
l'insolence de la jeunesse dans la très
vénérable d'honneur du palais des papes
et fier vif costumes éclatants de fête
foraine pour cette parade mise en
musique par erik satie
l'hommage au ballet russe débute brio et
ironie
les ballets russes
bien que du début du siècle c'est la
première compagnie de danse
contemporaine du monde et de l'histoire
de la danse
autre référence pour tous les danseurs
le spectre à la rose revisité par an
flins prejlocaj voici comment la danse
magnifie l'amour ici charnelle
romantique en contrepoint avec ses deux
demoiselles rêvant à des toréadors dans
une chorégraphie de style classique
de la délicatesse à l'étreinte le désir
et alors
dès qu'on touche au corps en touche en
ce sens et donc à une sensualité et
c'est important de retrouver dans le
corps la sensualité sinon sinon ce
serait un non sens presque à moi vous
encore et toujours l'amour sur une
partition de stravinsky des noces après
violente
angelin prejlocaj aux la sensualité dans
tous ses états
fin de ce journal la météo